well breaking news the jury is due to
return its verdict in the battery and
defamation case against Donald Trump our
U.S correspondent James Matthews joins
us live from New York and James we can
expect the verdict any minute now
that's right yeah we had notification
from inside the Jury Room that they were
ready they had made their decision and
they would be announcing it around no so
they will be filing in to court number
26b on the 26th floor of the Manhattan
Federal Courthouse behind me a busy
place this building last week we had Ed
Sheeran here you'll remember he won his
case of copyright infringement today
Eugene Carroll is inside there she is
Donald Trump's accuser accusing him of
having raped her in 1996. it was an
episode she said that began when she was
leaving a department store Bergdorf
Dorman when she went out to this
building she bumped into Donald Trump
now she was an advice columnist for L
magazine she hadn't met Trump he hadn't
met her but he recognized her he said oh
you're the woman who gives advice she
said you're Donald Trump they were
getting on well he said to her well look
I'm buying a gift for a female friend
why don't you give me some advice so the
two of them went in uh to this
department soon it was all good humored
according to Eugene Carroll they went to
the lingerie department and he asked her
to try on a garment they ended up in a
dressing room and that is where aging
Carol said that while she tried to fight
off the former president he raped her
now that was 1996. she didn't see
anything publicly about that but she did
call two friends one of whom encouraged
her to report the police to the police
but she never did it was only in 2019 at
the height of the me too movement that
EG and Carol decided to go public and
she did so by making these allegations
in a boot that she had published now
that book can that delay formed the
basis of Trump's defense and all of this
his lawyers have said continually
throughout this trial he has said
publicly that this was all about making
false accusations against a rich guy as
Donald Trump called himself in a bid for
fame for publicity and in an effort to
boost sales of this book the Trump
campus during this cold case they called
it outrageous called it a lie and
essentially accused eating Carol of
gaming the justice system so that was
the argument played out in court we will
hear a number of various from the jury I
I have in front of me the verdict form
that they were asked to to go through
and there are a number of questions that
they have to answer there are a number
of sexual offenses that they will have
to address accusations a number of them
rape of which is the most serious
question one for example did Miss Carol
prove by a preponderance of the evidence
that Mr Trump raped Miss Carol a
preponderance of the evidence that means
was it more likely than not that this
took place unanimous verdicts are needed
in each of these individual verdicts and
we talk about the preponderance of
evidence here in the states they are
equivalent in the UK is a balance of
probabilities that's the way it works in
a civil action it's a lower standard of
proof than in a criminal case which of
course is beyond reasonable doubts so
you know we're talking about 51 51
percent in the minds of a unanimous jury
that this incident took place that would
be enough for the jury to side with each
and Carol Donald Trump's accuser and of
course if they do then that is a New
York Court branding Donald Trump a
rapist and everything that comes with
that financial compensation
certainly but also reputational forward
and
James of course we're waiting for that
uh verdict to be released and just just
whilst we do remind us how it came about
that this this case was brought of
course given that it dates back to 1996
and typically traditionally that there
would have been the statute of
limitations
yeah exactly the the time clock would
have been running on that but that
doesn't apply in terms of this
particular case because in the state of
New York victims of sexual assault were
given a 12-month window to make our
historic historical allegations uh
Eugene Carroll took advantage of that
and on the very first day of that
12-month period she and her legal team
brought this to court that's why it
happened in 1996 and yet it is being
heard here in May 2023 so she's taken
advantage of a New York tweak in the law
and legal access to Legal redress the
justice that she believes that she
deserves while we're waiting for the
verdict well let's show you some video
now this was key in terms of the case
against Donald Trump it was his
deposition he never gave evidence in the
witness box but he did give evidence on
video he was questioned about the whole
Affair now bear in mind that he said
he'd never met Eugene Carroll and in any
case she wasn't his type he was shown a
photograph during this video q a
in which in that photographic frame he's
seen standing next to Eugene Cara also
he confuses his accuser with Marla
Maples she's in the same photograph
that's his ex-wife so the attorney for
aging Cannell says well that shows he
had indeed met her before
and that shows that she was very much
his type let's show you some of that
video now
there's like Marvel's in this photo
that's Marla yeah that's that's my wife
which one woman are you pointing each
other now here
oh the first thing you just pointed
to was oh yeah
and the person the woman on the right is
your then wife I don't know this was the
picture I assumed that's John Johnson is
that because it's very blurry
well we have the Jewish first verdict
and Reuters are reporting from inside
court that Donald Trump did not rape e
Gene Carroll that's the verdict that he
clearly wanted to hear that jury of six
men
but the jury has found that Donald Trump
did sexually abuse Eugene cattle that
was the lesser of the sexually sexual
assault
charges
and the jury has awarded Eugene Cattle
two million dollars
in compensation for that battery claim
so to repeat the jury has decided that
Donald Trump did not rape egn Carroll
but they have decided that he did
sexually abuse her
consequently they have awarded EG and
Carol two million pounds in compensation
that's three questions addressed by the
jury there are further questions to be
addressed
namely on defamation Donald Trump
accused eating Carol of lying about this
incident she's been suing him for
battery and defamation we will get to
the defamation verdicts very shortly
indeed why don't we just uh break down
James exactly just just to remind uh
remind viewers exactly what's uh crossed
in these last few moments so uh the
headline of course uh being that uh the
jury did not find uh that Donald Trump
raped e Gene Carroll but uh did uh find
that uh Trump sexually abused her uh and
they have awarded E.J Carroll at two
million dollars in compensatory damages
in terms of the defamation they have
awarded Carol twenty thousand dollars in
punitive damages uh and uh found that
Trump did defame Carol in an October
2022 truth social uh posts when uh he
called her a con job uh and uh has
awarded her 2.7 million in
compensationary Damages for uh
defamation and some more of these are
crossing as we speak as James was saying
there were a lot of individual different
verdicts to be announced and they're
also awarding a further 280 000 dollars
in punitive damages for uh defamation so
we've seen a two million award a 2.8
million award and a 280 000 uh dollar uh
award and the headline being that Donald
Trump was not found to have raped Eugene
Carroll but was found to have sexually
uh abused her let's bring James back in
and and qualify for us James I mean you
said at the top just just purely because
that first line that crossed where he
wasn't found to have raped her as if if
as if he would have been that that's a
result he would have been looking for
but uh the rest are not the decisions he
would have been looking for qualify for
us how this plays for for for Donald
Trump I mean this is pretty much as bad
as it could have been is it not
it's not good uh What I would say first
and foremost well first that this was a
very important verdict for the woman at
the heart of this case e Gene Carroll
who
came to court saying that in 1996 she
was attacked by this individual and her
life essentially was ruined there wasn't
just the brutality of the incident in
the department store but ever since her
life uh essentially ended she has
suffered the mental scars she has been
unable to function normally to build
relationships she lost her job and that
plays in to that compensation Award of
well more than two million dollars it
was a a marketing expert brought in by
her legal team to to taught up how much
she would have earn and how much she
would have benefited financially from a
burgeoning career had this incident not
taking place and their assessment was
around the 2 million dollar Mark so it's
clearly a Vindication for Eugene Carlin
having bought this case so many years
after the incident took place for Donald
Trump it is a very dark episode in a
relatively dark story I mean this is a
complicated controversial figure always
has been politically he's now in the
eyes of a New York Court a sex offender
a jury has ruled that he's sexually
abused a woman in 1996 and that is a
charge and that is a label that he will
have to carry with him from no forward
Carry It Forward into a presidential
campaign this is a man who's facing 34
criminal charges in a Courthouse 100
yards that way we saw him appear there a
few weeks ago he's a man facing criminal
investigations with regard to the
January the sixth Insurrection with
regard to the possible mishandling of
classified documents with the alleged
effort to overturn the election result
in Georgia in 2020. now that's a lot of
legal baggage for any individual to
carry forward in life let alone a third
presidential campaign and you know
there's something else about today
though that perhaps distinguishes it
from the other legal baggage that he is
carrying and that's the nature of the
offense he during his video deposition
when talking about rape he called that
the worst charge what certainly was the
worst charge on the sheet that was laid
out in front of him here
sexual abuse isn't very far behind and
there is a stigma that comes to an
individual who has been ruled to have
sexually abused another individual
that's the reason they are segregated in
prison it's a stigma that carries in to
wider society and one wonders how that
will play for him as an individual in
business and in politics you know he's
always played this strategy and played
it very successfully this victimhood
stick whereby he on his various public
platforms
we'll talk about how he is a victim and
that plays with his support base who see
Donald Trump and his fortunes through
the prism of Injustice one wonders if
having him labeled as a sex offender
makes a difference to that
James Matthews uh thanks so much for
that and we're going to keep discussing
this uh but before we do just just uh uh
sum up again exactly what we've learned
in the last five to ten minutes uh
firstly uh the Euros the jury in New
York that did not find uh that Donald
Trump raped E.G and Carol but they did
find that he sexually abused her and
they awarded uh Eugene Carroll two
million dollars in compensatory damages
for Battery Plus 2.7 million dollars in
compensatory damages for defamation
there were further cash Awards of twenty
thousand dollars and two hundred and
eighty thousand dollars uh related to
other areas including punitive damages
for defamation taking the total award to
around five million dollars for all of
the charges combined joining me now Sean
Spicer who served of course as the 28th
White House Press sector in the White
House communications director under
president Donald Trump in in 2017
um Sean Spicer joins me now Sean what is
your take on on on this verdict
well I'm hearing about it pretty much as
you're reading it uh so I think one of
the things again I just emphasize I'm
not a lawyer but but keep in mind that
this is a civil proceeding not a
criminal proceeding uh so the standards
are very different in our criminal
justice system and I think that that's
that is a very big difference that you
don't have to have a preponderance of
guilt in the Civil uh realm as you do in
the criminal uh and so that is a big big
difference in the criminal you have to
have a unanimous and I think the Civil
is just a majority so it's a very
different standard uh it is New York
which isn't exactly the friendliest of
venues for president Trump
um so again I think I'm reading this as
your or I'm listening to this and
evaluating as you're reading it out uh
it's never a good thing to have a
verdict against you I mean let's be
clear especially of this nature but I
think when it came to the big charge
that you're referring to uh that would
have that would have probably not gone
over very well on the campaign Trail
um and I think that's the bigger issue
is that Optics do matter in politics but
I think if you're president Trump right
now uh you're probably resting easy when
it came to the the charge of rape would
have stung a lot
I I I'm sure you're not implying that
the charge of sexual assault won't sting
um and I do get Sean you're you're
pointing out the differences between
criminal and civil and this is a civil
case no criminal charges have been
brought but this was a jury of six men
and three women who unanimously agreed
that it was more likely than not that he
had sexually abused someone I mean if
you were still his press secretary going
to the podium would you be trying to
defend him right now
well again I mean to to be blunt I mean
you're asking a a job of a press
secretary would be to defend your client
now that that's a so
from from what your your question is
would you be trying to defend them
that's the job of of a press secretary
for a principle
um I I think so let's be honest about it
there's technicals there about how I
worded the question I mean I guess the
point is he's lost a trial it was a
civil one not a criminal one but there
were six men and three women who
unanimously agreed to this verdict I'll
put it a different way would you
struggle to work for him sir would you
resign instead of defending him if he
told you to do that but look look
Wilford as I just said look I I I'm
literally hearing this as as you're
reading it so the first thing I would do
is get all the facts and I would try to
understand what the nature of it was I
honestly as an American that has heard
about this for a while wasn't even aware
that this was one of the charges that
was available so I didn't even know that
I I my understanding from the American
Media with this was entirely uh a case
about rape uh I didn't know that this
was a charge that was even available to
the jury uh so I would be asking lawyers
what this means
um what the difference between uh the
two charges were in terms of uh what the
the
the the legal ramifications were and
what the judge's orders were but I mean
the first thing would be to do exactly
what I'm doing now which is to
understand the nature of the law because
I don't know it and I'm hearing it as
you're putting it out
okay I mean it's sexual assault uh and
it's five million dollars of Damages so
so I don't know uh exactly again I I
think I've made clear it is never a good
thing so I just want to be clear on that
I'm not in any way trying to dismiss the
severity of a chart there is a
difference in our Judicial System
between civil and criminal I am not a
lawyer I don't know the difference in
the nature between them you're asking me
what I would do and my answer to you
would be that I would try to understand
the difference between the two in terms
of the legality of it before I would
answer the question but from from an
optic standpoint of course it doesn't
look good yeah I mean they're both
illegal and they're both immoral and
they're both wrong but anyway let's just
switch focus a little bit because I'm
interested uh in how you think
all of this plays
um because clearly anything seems to
bounce off him of late and and how do
you think leading up to this case it was
being framed as a Witch Hunt perhaps at
times against him does the does the
verdict uh change that significantly now
do you think did he need to be cleared
for for this to continue down the path
of many framing this is political
motivations or do you still believe that
there are political motivations
well I think as you said at the outset I
mean the president Trump has been over
not just the last couple of years but
frankly the last couple decades been
attacked politically for several
different things and it's always bounced
off of them so I don't know that this
will have any difference on them uh
we'll have to wait and see but I also
think that the way that the district
attorney went after president Trump
several weeks ago has tainted the
process against him he has been able to
say going forward you see these folks
are after me writ large
um and I think that defense
because of the nature of the way that
the district attorney in New York went
after president Trump I think that that
might taint the entire system going
forward and make his his claim that this
is quote a political Witch Hunt have a
lot more resonance
but would you personally reject that
given that we've reached a point where
this so I'm not trying to be tricky here
I'm generally just thinking of that it's
interested that we've now reached a
point where this was a unanimous
decision by nine members of a jury so so
even if the motivations to get to the
point of a court case if that's what
you're saying have political motivations
we've got nine members of a jury who
unanimously have decided something here
no nine members of a civil case made a
decision and again as I stated at the
outset I'm not a lawyer and I'm hearing
it from you at the time I I don't make
decisions like that and I would caution
anybody who is being asked a question
like this to actually get the facts and
understand them before they make it
because you've used words like illegal
and it's not a court of law it's a civil
case and so that's my point is that when
you throw around words like that and
mislead audiences that's part of the
problem so what I would urge people to
do is to get facts and then make a
decision before they make snap decisions
about their interpretation of what was
what was said or done or or decided and
that's what I will do as a citizen
Sean Spicer thanks so much for joining
us much appreciated
let's just uh recap exactly what we've
learned uh in the last uh 30 minutes or
so of course the verdict has been
returned in the Civil uh case against uh
former president uh Donald Trump and uh
they did not find uh that he raped e
Gene Carroll they did find that he
sexually uh abused her and then a number
of different Awards uh totaled close to
five million dollars in Damages that are
due of course uh to Eugene Carroll let's
go back to our James Matthews of course
who's uh outside the courtroom and has
been covering this uh closely uh for us
and James your perspective again uh on
this uh this verdict uh having had a few
moments to pause and reflect
yeah well thanks Wolf I think it's a
Vindication to a large extent of Eugene
cattle a woman uh you know who was
doubting and those doubts were led by
Donald Trump himself that's partly why
he will have now to pay five million
dollars in compensation to Eugene
Carroll and also in punitive damages
because when he accused her of lying uh
this jury found that he did so willfully
and maliciously in full knowledge of the
consequences that would have the
exposure to ridicule that that would
create for this woman who was high
profile she worked as a an advice
columnist for L magazine had a thriving
budgeting career and her argument in
court was that this brutal incident
where she claimed she had been brutally
attacked by an individual she was trying
to fight off in this dressing room on
one of the upper floors of a New York
Department Store quite a part from the
that particular incident she said that
in the wake of that her life changed she
has since been mentally scarred unable
to form uh Intimate Relationships her
career went South and essentially she
has struggled ever since that incident
in
1996. she was given the opportunity by a
tweak in the law in New York state to
bring this case so long after the
incident took place when normally there
would have been a statute of limitations
law that essentially timed her out but
she took this opportunity so many years
on having been encouraged she said by
the metoo movement to write a book to
make these allegations public in the
year 2019 and you know she came to court
told her story was ridiculed to a large
degree by the legal attorneys for Donald
Trump called her a liar called her
outrageous we saw Donald drunk didn't we
telling Sky News on an Irish Golf Course
about what you know how outrageous this
was how these were false accusations
against a rich guy our hopes he called
it he was on true social his media
social media platform an hour and a half
ago complaining that he hadn't been
allowed to give evidence in court that
was true that was untrue contradicted by
the facts because the judge gave him
until 5 PM on Sunday to make an
appearance here but he declined to turn
up in person the lawyers for his accuser
said that was a sign this man didn't
want to come anywhere near this case
because he knew how Brave it would be
for him and how accurate these claims
and accusations against him were one
thing I'd say wilf is you know going
forward there's much talk about how this
will affect Donald Trump the Fuller
there will be for his reputation and for
his political fortunes
not more than a year ago I would suit
outside race Rover's football ground in
five
player called David Goodwill you might
remember now he's an individual who in
it was the subject of a civil action no
criminal charges but a civil action and
a civil jury in Scotland found that he
had raped a woman that ruined his career
River signed him but there was a
national outcry and he hasn't been able
to play football again since such has
been the the backlash and the stigma
associated with his crime now that was
rape this is a very serious sexual
offense short of rape or be it but one
does wonder how the stigma of that
particular offense plays in
to the Donald Trump and the Donald Trump
strategy of of claiming Injustice of
shouting down critics of shutting down
reality in some cases so that the noise
drones out the detail that he doesn't
want to impinge on his personal and
political Ambitions he has a a staunch
support base that views him his life his
political fortunes
through the prism of victimhood he
encourages that at every turn
and that has worked in terms of the
criminal charges he faces and other
criminal investigations one wonders if
the same applies when he has been
labeled a sex offender
well indeed James and I guess it's not
actually just what the offense uh is
which as you said obviously carries a
terrible stigma with it the the other
point to note is that over the last
let's say six months it's been a case of
charges brought against him which might
be easier for him to frame as
politically motivated but we're now
talking about a verdict uh as discussed
with our previous guest from a from a
nine person uh Judiciary Judiciary a
nine-person jury excuse me uh with it
with a unanimous decision I mean just
reflect for us on the way in which in
the last three four months his poll
numbers have been improving while more
charges have been brought against him
um we can't necessarily draw precise uh
causation but there has been correlation
and the question now whether a verdict
going against him changes uh that
ongoing correlation
yeah yeah that that's that's the that's
the big question with Donald Trump isn't
it it's he has a strategy of whereby uh
he turns disadvantage into Advantage
when it comes to
particularly the criminal investigations
that he faces
he characterizes that as a weaponized
political
establishment pursuing him for reasons
of
political expediency and
that resonates with his support base to
the extent that he has enjoyed a bounce
in recent weeks on the back of the 34
criminal charges that he faces in
connection with the hush money to the
porn star in the face of other criminal
investigations that remain pending and
may yet result in a tap of the shoulder
tap on his shoulder in the weeks and
months to come you know that support
base that the trumpists in his
particular loyal particularly loyal
constituency they buy that they buy
that argument that he is a target of the
of the establishment of the other side
of a very partisan divided political
landscape something's happening behind
me will here's Eugene Carroll coming out
of court and I wonder if she will come
towards the microphone it doesn't appear
to be the case right now let's go and um
and I will look and we'll walk to where
we are she's heading towards a vehicle
uh in the company of her legal team and
to your point
uh wolf yes Donald Trump has enjoyed the
bounce yes he is doing well in the polls
in fact one in the past 24 hours has him
ahead of Joe Biden in the wake of uh you
know this labyrinthine criminal
labyrinthine series of Criminal
investigations that he faces I suppose
the difference about this case is that
we're not talking about a political
establishment we're not talking about
partisan politics we're talking about
human beings human beings with a story
to tell not necessarily with any ax to
grind I mean Eugene Carl was painted as
Somebody by Trump's legal team as
somebody who hated him and was motivated
by hate he was trying to encourage
hatred amongst members of the jury but
you know she's a woman who had an
experience in the company of Donald
Trump a very dark experience that she
came to court to share because she felt
she had to in the interests of herself
and in the the interests of wider
Society she was driven by the metoo
movement to make her allegations public
and she was supported in court by two
other women who who came to speak to the
behavior of Donald Trump two women who
claimed that They too had been assaulted
by Trump assaulted in a way that
actually had been made public on video a
video that was played in court you might
remember the notorious Access Hollywood
tape in which Donald Trump was recorded
talking about how when you are a star
you can grow up women and they allow
that to happen
to
two women came to court to speak to
being
dropped by Donald Trump to being subject
to his unwanted advances I believe
Donald Trump has responded to some
degree wolf I think you have that detail
yeah as indeed James uh on true social
he's just posted quote I have absolutely
no idea who this woman is this verdict
is a disgrace a continuation of the
greatest Witch Hunt of all time and to
viewers uh just uh joining us let's just
recap exactly what we've learned since
the top of the hour as the verdict was
returned in this civil case against
former president Donald Trump the jury
found that Donald Trump did not rape e
Gene Carroll uh but they did find that
Donald Trump sexually abused e Gene
Carroll uh a number of financial awards
for this totaled uh five million dollars
of course a reminder this is a civil
case not a criminal case and in order to
reach that verdict was required a
unanimous decision by the nine members
of the jury based on a preponderance of
the evidence meaning that they felt it
was more likely to be the case than not
and as just mentioned uh former
president Donald Trump has responded
saying quote I have absolutely no idea
who this woman is this verdict is a
disgrace a Contin continuation of the
greatest Witch Hunt of all time uh end
quote EG Carroll has been seen leaving
the courthouse but got immediately into
a car and didn't make any further
comments so joining me now Richard
painter the former Chief White House
ethics lawyer under George W bush thanks
so much for for joining me
um what's your take on this verdict
well this is a case for uh sexual uh
abuse and defamation and any American uh
anybody who comes uh to uh our country
and commits such acts is going to be
liable as is true in many countries
around the world uh defamation is a
civil tort and so is sexual abuse there
is no exception for presidents or former
presidents no one is above the law and
Donald Trump has been found liable he
can appeal uh and uh try to evade this
verdict I think his chances are quite
slim of winning on appeal uh but he will
have to pay the damages uh if he does
not and once again no one is above the
law is there any grounds any legitimacy
when people say oh but this isn't a
criminal case and the bar is lower in
order to to reach a verdict like this
well it's true in a civil case uh the
bar is lower and one does not have to
prove the claim Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt uh but uh still to lose a civil
case such as this one uh the defendant
has to engage it's an in some very
egregious behavior and uh once again
this behavior is uh not abnormal for uh
Donald Trump I mean this is the man who
was elected president of the United
States uh shortly after release of a
tape in which he talked about grabbing
women by their private parts uh and uh
Donald Trump has a long history of this
type of Behavior Uh so it's not
surprising that uh this incident uh
would have happened as a gene Carroll
accounted the incident uh and uh the
jury believed her and uh that's uh where
we are right now I mean you mentioned
there that that Infamous uh Locker Room
video uh audio clip of him that didn't
derail his 2016 bid do you feel that
this uh this particular verdict civil as
it is as opposed to criminal will
resonate with the American people in a
far more severe and negative way for
president Trump or will he be able to
somehow see it bounce off him
well we'll see what uh uh how people
feel about this but uh think about the
broader picture I mean this is the man
who uh sent a violent mob to the United
States Capitol on January 6 of 2021 who
sought to overturn a democratic election
uh who was impeached by the House of
Representatives twice uh uh for high
crimes and misdemeanors uh who is
currently
facing criminal charges in Manhattan
another grand jury investigating him in
Georgia for a solicitation of election
fraud not to mention the U.S Department
of Justice in connection with the
Insurrection of January 6. Donald Trump
has an enormous number of legal problems
both civil and criminal at this stage
and I would be very shocked if the
American people would want to reelect
him as president and quite frankly I'm
surprised that the Republican party is
entertaining the idea of running Donald
Trump for president in 2024 they have
plenty of candidates who have not been
indicted who have not been found viable
for a sexual abuse and defamation uh and
who don't have the other legal problems
of Donald Trump
um I wonder what your view is towards
this idea that there's some form of of
Witch Hunt uh against him and that some
of these legal matters have political
motivations I mean clearly the result of
this case is is the result of this case
um previously though that this would
have been protected by the statute of
limitations because it took place in
1996 until a New York law was passed to
create a 12-month window for past cases
to be brought I mean
as I said clearly the result uh the
verdict is the verdict and that's what
really matters but but what's your view
on that I mean does he have any argument
to hide behind uh in that regard that
there's political motivations
a lot of States uh in the United States
have been extending their statutes of
limitations for sexual abuse in
particular uh because of the scandals in
the church and in youth organizations uh
where people never brought claims uh
years ago uh and they're different
extensions of statutes of limitations
some pertain only to minors some pertain
to adults and every state has made
different adjustments but this is not a
an overall trend in the law that's aimed
at Donald Trump uh rather it's aimed at
holding those who engage in sexual abuse
accountable
um in terms of the the case that we were
talking about earlier relating to
Breaking election law
um uh based on a payment made to Stormy
Daniels again is that something that you
you think there's any grounds to to the
argument of political motivations in
well that that case is about
falsification of business records uh
which is a crime in the state of New
York and it's a felony if you falsify
the business records in order to cover
up another crime the underlying crime
here was the crime that Donald Trump's
lawyer uh Michael Cohen went to jail in
connection with the federal
investigation of that that federal
election law violation but falsification
of business records is a serious crime
and New York needs to enforce that
statute not just uh vis-a-vis Donald
Trump but everybody unless New York
wants to become a laundromat for money
and covering money covering up crimes
all over the world uh so there's a very
legitimate uh cause of action their
criminal case now whether the prosecutor
can prove Beyond a reasonable doubt that
Donald Trump ordered the falsification
of the business records that remains to
be seen uh but I would insist that that
is a serious crime in New York if it can
be proven that you false classified
business records in order to cover up
another crime in any jurisdiction
including covering up the crime the
underlying crime could take place in
London but if we are falsifying a
business record in New York to cover it
up New York prosecutors cannot tolerate
that Richard painter thanks so much for
joining me uh this evening let's just uh
recap exactly what we've learned as the
uh verdict has been returned in the
civil case against former president
Donald uh Trump the jury unanimously
found that Donald Trump did not rape e
Gene Carroll but they did find that he
sexually abused her and across a number
of the charges they awarded damages to
Eugene Carroll that totaled five million
dollars Eugene Carroll left the
courthouse about 10 or 15 minutes ago
and immediately got into a car didn't
make any comments uh former president
Donald Trump has commented on Truth
social he said I have absolutely no idea
who this woman is this verdict is a
disgrace a continuation of the greatest
Witch Hunt of all time let's get back
out to our James Matthews so he's
outside the courthouse in New York and
uh James interesting there to get uh
Donald Trump's statement again going
down the line to suggest this is a Witch
Hunt with political motivations behind
it
yeah well that's worked for him before
hasn't it his counter attack continually
has been to to allege you know a
political Witch Hunt to talk about a
weaponized justice system that is out to
get him and that does resonate with his
core support and that's why in the wake
of criminal charges that he first faced
several weeks ago he saw a bounce in the
polls he saw a bounce in his fundraising
and you know when it comes to criminal
charges and the various investigations
that he faces across the board then that
seems to have worked that that view
through the prism of Injustice and
political persecution the question will
be what is the reaction in wider Society
but also amongst that Trump base to the
this particular
finding of this jury we're talking about
sexual abuse a sex offense he is a sex
offender in the eyes of a New York jury
and that can't play well in terms of his
coming presidential campaign it is a
label that he will have to carry with
him a man who's already carrying
considerable legal baggage and you know
fundamentally he has to justify this
finding and he also has to justify his
actions throughout this case on his
social media platform his reaction is
that he doesn't know who this woman is
well during this court case a court case
of which he chose not to turn up and
give evidence we saw a photograph a
photograph taken in the 80s of Donald
Trump in the company of his accuser in
the company of EG and Carol and it's not
as if she was any stranger or unknown
figure she was a very high pro profile
advice columnist for L magazine in that
same photograph there is John Johnson he
used to be a TV presenter an Anchorman
also Ivana Trump Donald Trump's wife at
that time was in the same picture so
these were individuals well known in
their own right in each other's company
and that would appeal to indicate that
Donald Trump was in her presence and
there's every reason for that court and
for that jury to believe cattle was much
of this case came down to credibility
and you have to look at Adrian Carl a
woman who described in fine detail the
events of 1996 of being attacked by
Donald Trump said that against the man
who denies all knowledge of her and yet
is presented with a photograph showing
the two of them together a man who last
week on an Irish Golf Course said I'll
come to court and I want to confront
this woman and to confront these charges
he never turned up despite the judge
giving him an extension giving him until
5 PM on Sunday to say that he would come
and tell his side of the story so
credibility was Central to this case and
clearly the jury fund The credibility
lay on the side of Donald Trump's
accuser
James Matthews thanks again for that
latest breakdown let's keep discussing
this Sarah Christoph a former Federal
prosecutor who has significant
experience her leading high profile
government investigations joins me uh
now thanks so much for joining us
most of all I just wanted for you to
break down for us uh and our our UK
predominantly UK based audience the
significance that this is a civil case
as opposed to to criminal and whether in
any way shape or format that lessens uh
the severity of the verdict
well this
well this against Donald Trump
um there there's no criminal case
related to this conduct so there are no
criminal charges there's no possibility
of of jail time or anything like that or
criminal penalties
um this is a civil case in the in the
penalties associated with that are
monetary which is what we saw we saw the
jury award
um the accuser uh Hefty sum here due to
the the harm that this conduct caused
her and and is it possible that criminal
uh criminal uh things can be brought
later or not
I I I don't think we're gonna see that
these are from events that happened long
ago
um and this really was a was a civil
matter at this point
um if if the
um if you had had Arisen back in the
1990s we we may have seen criminal
charges then but I don't think that is
is going to happen now and what is your
take on on this verdict uh overall and
the damages awarded
you know even the the former president
is going to do his best to Discount the
result here to to you know uh
uh draw Falls of the jury you know to to
attack his accuser or some more I I
fully expect to hear from Trump's camp
and and get that message but I think
this is a pretty significant blow we
have a jury an independent jury who've
heard the evidence against Donald Trump
and decided that this assault occurred
um and that the accuser was credible
that the people corroborating her story
were credible and that the Trump's team
was just not able to poke holes in the
story presented by the plaintiffs here
and and of course a hugely significant
moment for Eugene Carroll and uh one
that that might well bring strength to
people that that may feel they've
experienced something similar in their
past
absolutely and then
generally
um uh
violated by the former president that
evidence was allowed to come into this
trial
um and it but I think you know
um Ms Carroll's brought you know these
allegations to the world first in her
book and then decided to proceed with
this lawsuit part of that was because of
a change in the law that allowed her to
do that
um and because there's a long history of
allegations of this type of conduct sort
of being swept under the rug and and not
the people not being allowed to air
publicly
um their accusations and so she had now
has had the opportunity to do that and
frankly I suspect that opportunity is
more important to her than the monetary
judgment she received
um is the former president likely to
appeal and is is that a route he's
highly likely or unlikely to find
success down
you know I I think that you know the
president May uh make a statement about
this he is a hard time staying away from
the media
um and I'm sure his you know his team
speaks very vocally for him
um but he very well may come out and
talk about this you know he declined to
be at the trial he declined to testify
in the trial I mean all of those things
that I think hurt him
um in front of the jury particularly
with the kind of carefully
um and carefully drawn out in deliberate
case that was put on by it by Gene
Carroll's team so you know but but I
assume he will speak out his team will
speak out and try to distance himself
from the verdict in this case or
attribute it to a you know a rogue jury
in New York or something in that vein
Sarah Crystal thanks so much for joining
us very much uh appreciate it uh let's
bring in now our U.S correspondent Mark
Stone who joins us from from Washington
and and Mark uh the jury of course uh
rejects the allegations that Donald
Trump raped the writer at Eugene Carroll
but accepted other serious charges uh
including of course sexual uh assault
what do you think is likely to be uh the
impact here
well remember this is a man who said a
few years ago now that he could shoot
someone on Fifth Avenue and he would not
lose voters and
um so far that statement uh has has held
up as far as his base is concerned
um they stand by him through thick and
thin they have done through so many uh
cases against him so many things that he
is alleged to have done so many things
he has done and yet his base is still
very much behind him to the extent that
he is the presumptive nominee for the
Republican party for next year's
presidential election more than that
though his ratings are very very good if
you look at
um that the next closest contender in
the Republican lineup it is Rhonda
Santos has 20 support Donald Trump 43
support among Republican voters they
back him and that is a statement fact
the question is whether things like this
and more yet to come like the uh the
Georgia voting case that is uh that is
coming up really very soon whether he uh
tried to to steal votes to get someone
to to put votes into his bag uh whether
or not that uh impact things well
um talking to his base as we do up and
down the country whenever we travel
um they're either not listening to this
they don't believe it or like he says
himself they believe that this is just
the continuation of the greatest winter
Witch Hunt of all of all time two
interesting things to reflect on just in
the last few moments I've just had a
flick through at the right wing news
channels here in the U.S the likes of
Newsmax Fox News very very influential
news channels I'm interested that they
are covering this blanket coverage on
right-wing news channels
um that they're framing it maybe in a
slightly different way but they are
covering it which is certainly something
that is that is interesting I've just
got in touch with a someone um who I
keep in touch with from time to time a
real voter you might say up in
Pennsylvania who I gauge uh reaction
from every now and again and I said to
him what are your thoughts on he's a
very much a trump supporter I should say
what are your thoughts on the Aging e
Gene Carol verdict his response I'm not
familiar with that um I think he may be
being facetious but you can take from
that what you will
um this doesn't touch the sides when it
comes to the hardcore base of Donald
Trump's support the question though is
what it does to those undecided voters
and you look at the um the polling at
the weekend from ABC News undecided
undecided voters
um in a runoff between Trump and Biden
49 would vote for Donald Trump 42
percent would vote for Joe Biden I mean
Mark I'm interested because clearly with
with other cases that were being
discussed uh some have raised the idea
that he'd have to be campaigning from
behind bars that doesn't apply with this
case it's it's a it's a civil case that
said it is one that has now reached a
verdict uh and on such a toxic uh topic
of of uh suggesting uh or confirming
that he is sexually assaulted someone
and I guess whereas he's managed to to
shake off these court cases Brewing over
the last three or four months to lead
his poll numbers as you said to the to
the 40s having dipped significantly at
the back end of last year after the
midterm elections whether the fact that
we have now got to a verdict from a a
jury a unanimous decision of nine uh
jurors whether that changes the calculus
as to whether these these court cases
now affect him if and when we reach
verdicts
we'll see I I mean I have uh I've been
wrong in in um assuming uh what Donald
Trump's base would do many times uh
never assume uh what they might do
because uh they firmly stand by behind
him they believe him they think that he
is uh their Street Fighter he stands up
for them against the establishment and
they will see him doing that once again
they will believe him uh over uh e Gene
Carroll as they have done with other
defendants in other cases of all
different types over the course of the
past uh few years that is his base that
is his magic that is what he is able to
do against the odds and against what the
um the political commentators might
think I suppose there is a question over
what politicians here on Capitol Hill uh
will do now will they reflect on this
and and the cases that are to come down
the line
um will the the old guard of the
Republican Party who Donald Trump seems
to own at the moment uh will they begin
to Desert him will they look elsewhere
to the likes of Ron DeSantis the
governor of Florida that man with just
20 percent of of support among
Republican voters for the presidency
will he gain support as a consequence of
this will he take advantage of this
that's something that I think we we
could potentially see him using this but
of course even he and this goes to show
how how
um how valuable and how feared the Trump
uh base is even Rhonda Santos is very
very careful about upsetting uh the the
base support that he knows and so many
across this country know
um is so loyal to Donald Trump
just remind us again as well Mark in
terms of the timeline both the number
and the timeline of other cases and uh
accusations that that he might be facing
in the weeks and months ahead
well I think the most damning one of all
of them uh is is potentially the the one
in in Georgia this this suggestion that
he rang the Secretary of State in
Georgia and that he asked you'll
remember it was recorded because the
recording was released he asked the
Secretary of State in Georgia to find
votes find him votes uh and in order to
overturn and make him the winner of the
state of Georgia which would have had a
fundamental impact on the the election
itself that is a very important court
case certainly one to watch but there
are so many others as well
Mark Stone uh thanks so much for joining
us as ever from Washington and just a
reminder uh of the news this hour that a
jury has found that uh former president
Donald Trump did not rape E.G and Carol
uh but they did find him guilty of
sexual uh assault and across a number of
the charges awarded e Gene Carroll a
total of five million dollars uh in
Damages